president Trump is considering a series
of high-level changes in the White House
that may include a new chief of staff
retired General John Kelly status is
suddenly unclear in part because of
tensions with first lady
Melania Trump the first lady's office
stunned and stunned is a word they
stunned observers yesterday asking for a
deputy national security adviser
Mira Ricardo to be fired and sources
tell CBS News the upcoming departure of
homeland security secretary Kirsten
Nelson could set off a chain reaction in
the West Wing Paula Reid is at the White
House Paula sounds like palace intrigue
good morning palace intrigue indeed good
morning Gail they usually press shy
First Lady Melania Trump shocked people
yesterday when she released this
unprecedented public statement calling
for a cardinal to be fired after she
allegedly feuded with the first lady's
office chief of staff John Kelly and
defense secretary mattis and this comes
as an administration official tells CBS
News that there will likely be
significant staffing shakeups at the
White House over the next few weeks I
have my own voice and my opinions
First Lady Melania Trump heated clashes
with the president's chief of staff John
Kelly have reportedly included issues
like staffing and travel requests it's
very important for me that I I express
what I feel in a statement the first
lady's office denied there is any
conflict saying mrs. Trump has a very
positive relationship with chief Kelly
and there have never been any issues
between the two in a rare move the first
lady publicly called for deputy national
security advisor Mira Ricard el to be
fired
complaining directly to her husband
about being unhappy with her car del
during her first solo trip to Africa in
October the two fought over seating on
the plane and using National Security
Council resources for the trip less than
an hour after a Kartal was seen at the
White House yesterday the first lady's
office issued a statement saying she no
longer deserves the honor of serving in
this White House by beauty my honest
advice in an interview last month the
first lady said there were those in the
White House she did not trust you always
need to watch your back she said she
made sure the president knew and what
did he do when some people they don't
there anymore on Tuesday President Trump
ignored questions about reports that he
plans to remove Homeland Security
Secretary Christian Nielsen where are
you getting this from reports while his
advisor Kellyanne Conway
tried to cast doubt on anonymously
sourced reports why do they mean honest
could it be that it's not completely
verifying true
Nielsen's firing could potentially set
off a showdown between the president and
his chief of staff who has made it clear
that he opposes any firing of Nielson
now all of this palace intrigue is
providing a helpful distraction from the
ongoing legal controversy surrounding
the president's acting Attorney General
Matthew Whitaker an administration
official tells CBS News that the
president is waiting to see how big a
majority he gets in the Senate before
naming his permanent Attorney General
bianna alright Paula thank you